the past decade has left us with a good
share of movie mysteries from misplaced
lightsabers to dreaming mercenaries
here's what we think are the biggest
unanswered movie questions of the past
decade in Blade Runner Harrison Ford
plays the character of Deckard a cop
tasked with killing very specific
targets synthetic life forms known as
replicants they were designed the coffee
human beings in every way except their
emotions
the designers reckoned that after a few
years they might develop their own
emotional responses however one of the
biggest bones of contention between fans
and even people intimately involved in
making the film is the question of
whether or not its lead character is
himself a replicant in 2014 director
Ridley Scott told Digital Spy that
without a doubt he is definitely a
replicant Harrison Ford on the other
hand is on record saying Deckard is a
human and Ryder Hampton Fancher agrees
with him debating fans may have been
hoping that the film's 2017 sequel Blade
Runner 2049 would clear things up but if
so they were wrong similar to the
original film Blade Runner 2049 ends
without a definitive answer regarding
the question of deckert's humanity or
lack thereof we learned that Deckard and
the late replicant Rachele somehow
conceived a child and Jared Leto's
character Wallace gives us a monologue
exploring the question but we never
learned the truth either way it seems
likely this is one question that
audiences will have to accept will
remain unanswered for many years to come
exactly how does Maz Kanata get her
hands on Anakin Skywalker's lightsaber
the diminutive alien offers the
decades-old weapons array and her Tavern
on takodana in 2015 Star Wars The Force
awakens freaked out by force visions Rey
initially refuses it and as a result
finn is briefly its caretaker
however Rey finally takes it up in order
to defeat kylo Ren at the end of the
film but how did the lightsaber wind up
in takodana in the first place in order
of the skywalker saga narrative we first
see anakin skywalker's lightsaber in
2005's revenge of the sith anakin uses
it before his transformation into Darth
Vader and obi-wan Kenobi takes it from
Anakin when the latter is defeated at
the end of Revenge of the Sith Kenobi
gives Luke the lightsaber in 1977's a
new pope
no father wanted you to have this with
you little mouse the last time we see it
before the force awakens is in the
climactic battle between Luke and Vader
on the planet best bin at the end of
1980s the Empire Strikes Back the weapon
is in Luke's hand when Vader chops it
off sending it down the long shaft the
pair duel over so how exactly did the
saber make its way to a container in a
tavern on a different planet in a
different solar system a good question
for another time
well we really don't have a better
answer than the force willed it the
ending of 2010's inception is a kind
that's likely to be debated for years
and even decades to come
directed by Christopher Nolan the film
boasts a heavyweight cast including
Joseph gordon-levitt Tom Hardy and Ellen
Page among others Leonardo DiCaprio
plays its lead cop who's the head of a
crew of thieves specializing in
corporate espionage
Cobb and his team enter their victims
dreams steal information and plant ideas
into their subconscious mr. Saito this
this isn't your typical
corporate espionage you asked me for
inception I do hope you understand that
the gravity of that request one of the
dangers of their work is the risk of
being stuck in a dream without knowing
it so Cobb and his colleagues each carry
totems which are items that let them
know whether or not they're in a dream
Cobb carries a spinning top whenever he
doubts whether or not he's in a dream he
spins it and if the top doesn't stop
spinning
he knows he's still asleep inception
ends with Cobb testing his totem after
being reunited with his children but we
never learned whether or not the top
stops spinning Cobb spins the top on the
table then walks away the screen fades
to black with the top still spinning
Nolan later explained he ended the film
this way to demonstrate that to Cobb
it didn't matter whether or not he was
dreaming during his 2015 Princeton
commencement speech Nolan said Cobb
didn't really care anymore and that
makes a statement perhaps all levels of
reality or valid when the elderly Steve
Rogers gives Sam Wilson his shield at
the end of 2019 s Avengers end game it
may seem simple as far as time travel
plot points go Captain America goes back
in time to return the Infinity stones
and rather than return he decides to
stay in the past and spend as much of
the rest of his life as he can with
Peggy Carter then having lived much of
that life cap returns to the spot where
he was sent
can time and hands his shield over to
Sam what's confusing about that well
here's the thing when Steve Rogers goes
back in time and stays with Peggy Carter
he changes history and in doing so he
creates an alternate timeline while
speaking to Entertainment Weekly shortly
after the release of endgame directors
Joe and Anthony Russo said that caps new
life with Peggy does not take place in
the prime MCU timeline so if he lives in
this new splintered reality how does he
get back to the prime MCU reality in
order to hand the shield off to Sam
Wilson the Russos have admitted they
don't have an answer
Joe told Entertainment Weekly the
question then becomes how is Steve
Rogers back in this reality to give the
shield away interesting question right
maybe there's a story there in a world
like BMC use there's no shortage of
possibilities only time will tell if we
ever get a definitive explanation for
Steve Rogers as returned the Arthur
Fleck of 2019 s Joker lives in a fantasy
world early in the film Fleck imagines
himself in the audience of his favorite
late-night talk show eventually even
being called up to the stage by host
Murray Franklin later we learned he's
even imagined an entire romantic
relationship with his neighbor's Sophie
who in reality barely remembers his name
so when we learned that art there's time
with Sophie was all in his head it's
difficult not to call most or all of the
film's events into question when he
finally does show up on the Murray
Franklin Show for example even though
the host doesn't treat him as nicely as
he does in Plex earlier fantasy in many
ways his behavior seems just as
nonsensical he allows Arthur to save
horrible things on live TV he doesn't
pull the plug but instead argues with
Arthur until the failed comedian finally
kills the host on one extreme end of the
spectrum it could be that almost the
entire story is just flecks imagination
at the end of the movie Fleck is in a
mental institution earlier in the film
while Fleck talks to his social worker
there's a brief flashback of him
slamming his head into a door in the
same institution it could be that these
are the only real parts in the movie and
everything else is his fantasy either
way it's one of the biggest unanswered
questions in Joker and one we might
never get an answer to the acclaimed TV
series Breaking Bad ends with Jesse
Pinkman racing his way to freedom
after being enslaved as a meth cook for
a bunch of white supremacist he's
finally free and the Netflix movie El
Camino tells us what happens to Jesse
once he reaches civilization at
encountering some old friends
discovering a secret stash of cash and
running across some really bad dudes
Jesse finds ed the same guy who
relocated Walter White toward the end of
Breaking Bad and convinces the older man
to smuggle him all the way to Alaska
looking for a a Hoover max pressure max
max pressure Hoover or maybe cipro max
got like a filter once they're up north
jesse gives ad a letter addressed to
brock the son of andrea kenty oh and one
of the most soul-crushing moments of
Breaking Bad jesse is forced to watch as
the white supremacists kill Andrea as
punishment for him trying to escape as
for Brock he was left orphaned and
without a clue as to why his mother was
shocked
what does Jesse right to Brock well we
never get a chance to read the letter we
only see the envelope it's tough to
imagine what Jesse could possibly say to
the eight-year-old maybe it's better to
not know or our hearts might get broken
all over again
most post-apocalyptic films begin and
end with only a small portion of the
Earth's population left and snowpiercer
is no different in that respect in the
film all that's left of the human race
is confined to a train that protects
them from the fatal cold of a second Ice
Age what's different about snowpiercer
is that by the end of the film
it isn't clear how much of the human
race is left a cruel aristocracy rules
the locomotive of snowpiercer with the
poorest survivors confined to the tale
the heroic Curtis leads a revolt and
pushes his followers through the length
of the Train to the engine caretaker
Wilfred and when things start getting
desperate Swan of curtis's allies
namgoong sets off an explosive that
triggers an avalanche derail in the
Train and presumably killing most of the
people on board nice
in the film's final moments Jonah and
Timmy a teenage girl and a young boy
emerge from the train wreck the movie
ends just as they spot a polar bear
nearby
the explosion and the crash it causes
are dramatic enough that we have to
assume few survived but as far as the
named characters are concerned we never
know for sure we don't see the bodies of
Curtis namgoong or Wilfred if Jana and
Timmy really are all that's left at the
end of snowpiercer it doesn't seem like
humanity has long to go before the end
the warrior SIF has been missing from
the MCU since her appearance in Thor the
dark world she wasn't there for the
Battle of Pella she wasn't on the
Asgardian refugee ship and Avengers
infinity war and she wasn't with the S
Guardians in Avengers end game according
to Jaime Alexander she wasn't there for
Ragnarok because of a scheduling
conflict between the movie shooting
schedule and that of her TV series blind
spots SIF isn't mentioned in the film
but Marvel Studios President Kevin Feige
gave a narrative explanation connected
to Loki's secret usurping of the
Asgardian throne at the end of Thor the
dark world just as we learn in Ragnarok
that Loki had Heimdall branded a traitor
Mikey said Loki would want Thor's
closest friends as far away from Asgard
as possible so he found some reason to
exile her he said
SIF was probably banished she's off
somewhere however neither Feige nor
anyone else has bothered to specify what
somewhere means at the end of The Dark
Knight Rises the final installment of
director Christopher Nolan's Dark Knight
trilogy Bruce Wayne fakes his own death
but he doesn't seem content to leave
Gotham without a protector so he leaves
a parcel for police detective John Blake
whose first name we learned is Robin
that leads Blake to the Batcave and all
its secrets at the same time James
Gordon discovers the bat-signal has been
repaired the assumption seems to be that
what the batcaves Arsenal at his
disposal Blake will take up the mantle
of Batman to make sure Gotham still has
its protection against international
assassins and psychotic clowns but what
will happen more to the point could that
happen throughout the Dark Knight Rises
Blake proves himself dedicated to the
cause of justice which is likely why
Wayne chose him as a successor still he
can be as dedicated as he likes but it
doesn't change the fact that he's
missing some key components to being
Batman he doesn't have the billions of
dollars at Wayne's disposal as that's
largely left to his Butler Alfred and he
doesn't have someone like Alfred to
bandage
wounds or Lucius Fox to design new tech
he doesn't have the dual identity of a
billionaire playboy to help hide his
crime-fighting and perhaps more
importantly it doesn't have the decade
Wayne spent abroad training to avenge
his parents good Blake still bill
Wayne's shoes baby but it's hardly a
certainty and now that the movies have
moved on from this story we'll never
find out check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]